talk to me about investing pick stocks
or index funds and I'm like you're poor
here's the thing is when you when you do
the dollar cost average thing because
everyone likes to put in the Excel sheet
everyone gets Excel Rich the thing is is
that by the time you retire with four
million dollars on that Excel sheet four
million dollars will be a million
dollars today just not a lot of money
now people like that is a lot of money
it's not when you're trying to live on
it and you got like 30 more years to
live take the compounding of four
percent a year on inflation and do that
for 40 years and then see what the money
really looks like and whatever it is I
think it's around four percent people
aren't taking the inflation into account